good evening and welcome to statford on
aan District Council planning committee
my name is councelor Lewis Adam I'm your
chairman for this evening start with
some uh housekeeping uh there's no fire
uh drill plan for this evening so if the
fire alarm does go off uh please make an
orderly exit and the must point is the
car park by the pub across the road um
please make sure your phones are turned
off or at least on silent so that they
don't re
um uh mix up the flow of the meeting uh
this is a meeting in public not a public
meeting um only those who are registered
to speak are permitted to do so uh the
appropriate time I'll call you forward
and give you further instructions at
that point uh the meeting is also being
recorded and broadcast on our website
okay I'll now introduce our top table
from democratic Services we've got
Olivia Quinn our solicitor this evening
is Sue Mullins
our planning manager is David Jeff and
our planning officers are Neil Hemstead
Paul Thompson and Sarah flairty we also
have Richard Greenway who is our
forestry and Landscape officer uh who
will be advising on one of the
applications uh David I believe you have
a statement you have prepared thank you
chair my name is David Jeffrey I'm the
planning manager for this evening's
meeting my role is to provide impartial
advice to clarify any planning issues
that arise and to assist members
decision taking Plan ing committee
members are not bound by advice from
officers or by their recommendations
thank you thank you very much okay we
can now move on to the agenda item one
is apologies for absence chair we have
apologies from councilors Eden Curtis
hencher sarapin and councelor pton who
councelor lwood is currently
substituting for J good thank you very
much sorry was the council Holmes there
and Council H thank you very much
um item two disclosures of
interest
to thank you chair yes uh declare
interested in item six as um I am the
ward member for this um application and
I have uh registered my support
online okay Johnny good so you'll be
stepping down from the committee on that
item thank you very much any further
disclosure of interest uh I'll raise one
just uh as a better safe and sorry on
item five move um application
7f um I understand from um that there's
an enforcement case on that uh
associated with that area I was notified
of that at um earlier in the year when a
similar enforcement case was made um in
my ward and there was an understanding
they may be related it turns out they
were not related I have no prior
information about that case and remain
uh with an open mind and so we'll be
sitting on the committee for that that
case Okay um we now move on to item
three then which is
minutes uh we have minutes from the
meeting held on the 27th of September
2023 um we've all had opportunity to
read them are we agreed that they are of
true reflection of the
meeting agreed really good okay we can
now move on to our first item then which
is application 22
23627 ful landoff shipston Road Ellmore
our presenting officer is Neil Hamstead
when you're ready to take it away thank
you chairman um the application site is
shown on the screen with the um with the
black dot um members will be aware of
the background to this
application um as detailed in the
committee report and it was previously
withdrawn from the committee agenda on
the 11th of October in order to obtain
an updated response from County highways
um a response of no objection was
received on the 18th of October and
that's as detailed in the committee
update
sheet so just looking at the site in
more detail that's the application site
outlined in red
there and looking closer in on the site
the proposed
um building is going there the
agricultural building is proposed there
there is some existing hard standing on
the site which was granted last year
under an agricultural notification and
that has been
implemented so I'll show you some plans
first of all but then I'll show some
photographs and just just to give
members some context effectively I'll be
looking into the site and then sort of
looking West westwards and then North to
where the building is going to go so
that's just to give some context moving
forward some reference points will be
the
hardstanding and some of the stock proof
fencing just to the South here and along
the boundary so if you keep those in
mind just just for the
photographs so in terms of the
Agricultural building which is proposed
these are the
elevations so it's um an open fronted
building relatively simple in
form um and then looking at the floor
plans you can see it's divided into
effectively three three sections if you
like two will be to house some
machinery and then the others will be
for some for um lamming and some um
storage of hay so just looking at the
the 3D view you can see the open fronted
nature effectively the three bays and
some of the Machinery which is proposed
to be contained within the
building so just looking at some of the
photographs so this is looking South
into the site so with where the
agricultural building will be would be
behind where I'm taking this Photograph
so that's the the sort of the stock
proof fencing that I was referring to
along the boundary previously with the
grass area in
front and then looking further west
again you can see some of the hard
standing which was granted under the
agricultural notification procedure
and the the stock proof
fencing and continuing around you can
see the adjoining plot of land with the
existing agricultural building on so
this is the grass
area where the agricultural building is
proposed to be
located so you can see it just here so
that's the the existing road in front
with the B existing boundary treatment
and
trees and just going going further round
that's the existing access into the site
which feeds into some of the hard
standing so chairman there are updates
as detailed in the update sheet and as
referenced before before including a
consultation response from County
highways stating no objection together
with a number of suggested conditions
and notes and chairman the
recommendation is for approval thank you
thanks very much Neil okay we'll now
move move on to our first Speaker who is
Martin Cole from braille's Parish
Council good evening councelor
Cole uh so you've got three minutes um
it's the button on the right hand side
to uh make the microphone live and um
are you happy for me to give you a 30
second warning yes y okay in which case
when you're ready uh take it
away good evening
counselors uh this application as you
can see is set in a very tranquil rural
setting in the the North End Of The
Village brails between ships nonar and
toyso these are the parish council
comments the parish council all agreed
to object to this application as they're
very concerned that the application may
be in future for the purpose of building
a house Parish Council seek assurances
that this will not be the case and that
the buildings are strictly what is
required and no larger and will will
definitely be used for the purpose of
agricultural not a stealth way of uh
gaining a planning permission in the
future for a residential dwelling they
are
still uh not certain about the size of
this present uh
building on the first application it was
a class as a 3 Acre Site with the hard
standing that has reduced it down to 2
point something so that is actually
giving you a lot less available pasture
etc for the proposed amount of animals
to be kept can I remind the council
please on the 27th of September here
four counselors had a site meeting this
is the same field but the other
end o of it uh 4 this building is 400
meters away and they were looking at a
redundant barn and this cter committee
here thank you Mr chairman
thank you very much well within your
time members do we have any questions
for our Parish
counselor no nothing coming forward in
which case thank you very much for your
contribution this
evening okay we now move on to our next
speaker who is Natasha Blackmore D Silva
agent for the
applicant good
evening uh so likewise you have 3
minutes are you happy with a 30 second
warning y okay uh when you're ready take
it
away good evening I'm here to speak in
support for this revised application for
an Agricultural building at withy
creamfields Farm following on from the
original planning committee the
application was deferred so that it
could be assessed by an independent
agricultural consultant for an an expert
opinion Fox rural were instructed by the
council to undertake an assessment of
the proposals as per their
recommendations the scheme has been
revised to remove the second building
towards the top of the field and to
reduce the size of the remaining
building Fox R have confirmed their
support for the resid scheme stating
that the amended proposal is considered
to be appropriate in scale and design
and considered reasonably necessary for
a small holding mixed
Enterprise therefore this smaller bar
meets a genuine need that has been
assessed and accepted by the agriculture
consultant this also alleviates the
Parish council's main reason for
objection at committee two weeks ago
this item was deferred again pending
confirmation from the highest Authority
that their no objection from SE
September remained they have now
confirmed their no objection therefore
both reasons for deferral have been
dealt with councelor Wally hoggins
visited the site on the 7th of October
to take some photos and met with the
client the applicant gave her a tour and
answered some questions she was made
aware of the applicant's farming family
background and that they had bought
additional land since the original red
line was drawn she stated that she was
pleased with the track that had been put
in place as it kept mud off the road and
confirmed to them that she was happier
with the smaller open fronted Barn
design and the fact that it would not be
visible from the road she informed them
that while she was unable to support the
application due to the application on
the corner being at appeal she would put
a paragraph in Her speech saying that
she was happier with the revised design
and their intentions for the site as you
can imagine they were surprised after
such a positive site meeting that Not
only was it not mentioned at all but
many of the photos taken were not shown
during the committee
further to the last committee I just
wanted to provide some clarification on
the points raised by members and the
ward member and a few inaccuracies that
I did not have an opportunity to address
last time in addition to the land within
the red line the applicant now owns the
adjacent square parel of land and he is
also continuing to look for land to
further expand the
holding to clarify this building is not
as previously suggested a means to
expand a storage business into the
countryside or to convert a building
into residential use further along this
building is designed to meet a solely
agricultural purpose if approved the
officer has suggested a condition
restricting use to solely agricultural
which the applicant will happily accept
also due to its height position with the
site and existing mature tree screening
the building will not be visible from
outside of the field and therefore will
not have a visual impact on the wider
setting in summary Fox rule were
consulted as per member's earlier
request and have confirmed that the
resized scheme is appropriate in scale
and is necessary for the Enterprise the
highways Authority have also now
confirmed their no objection to the
scheme we hope that this is a
straightforward decision to approve the
scheme in line with case officer
recommendation and highways officer
updated response thank you very much um
perfect on time okay members do we have
any questions for the agent for the
application again nothing forthcoming in
which case thank you very
much okay uh we now move on then to to
our final speaker of the evening who's
the W member councelor W
hoggins good evening
councelor so you know the drill it's 5
minutes happy to give you a 30 second
warning and uh otherwise when you're
comfortable feel free to take it
away first and foremost I'd like to say
that our Recollections of the
conversation that took place on the site
differ hugely the focus of this week's
application in asmore is the purpose of
this application is not proven and that
this Barn is not required the
photographs before you today demonstrate
the pitifully small amount of land that
the applicants are now referring to as
withiam Fields Farm there are many
people with Gardens bigger than this
field and they would not be permitted to
erect a building of this size because
they needed to mow their grass no more
than three times a year and to store
food the business plan submitted States
very clearly that they only have nine
sheep and a handful of poultry there are
other poultry Keepers with far more
chickens uh kept in gardens the
photographs provided by the applicants
are clearly taken with a wide- angle
lens and I have assisted the panel with
a crude boundary definition which shows
where the fence is to the neighboring
Paddock which is not clear on the
photograph that they submitted with
their application the photographs been
shown clearly demonstrate how ridiculous
the business plan is as the amount and
scale and cost of the equipment they
alleged needs to to be stored in the
barn along with the handful of bales
that this land produces for their
handful of sheep is clearly fictional
the submission from the CPR concludes
the following we ask that permission for
agricultural buildings whether barns or
Stables should not be granted unless you
can be sure that they are absolutely
essential to the applicant's needs I say
to this committee that a plot of land
that could be mowed using a conventional
mower does not need equipment of this
magnitude I've been careful to include
pictures of the exact brand and
specification of equipment listed in the
business plan the husband of nine Hardy
breed sheep does not require a shed
measur measuring 60 foot by 30 ft
precisely because two parles of land
have got planning commiss within 200
yards of this application we have before
us yet another application for yet
another barn on the tiniest Slither of
land imaginable which the owners have
start now started to rever to as a farm
when it is in fact a patch of grass
unable to sustain more than 10 sheep in
terms of grazing available grazing has
also been further reduced by the
substantial amount of hard standing
that's now been put down in advance this
plan planning application some might say
that they can only grow their business
if they have this storage nobody's
checked that they have the financial
resources to do this and the business
plan gives further evidence of the lack
of reality and understanding that they
have for how this patch of land is going
to sustain the business that they
propose much of the equipment shown
would however be very useful the primary
income of the applicant which is around
ran construction further conversations
this week with John careford the head of
planning regarding the need to stop
overdevelopment and Barn Building in
this area reveal the committee can
turned down this application because of
cs15 cs-16 CS5 and as10 all of which are
there to protect the precious parle of
open
Countryside this committee should be
protecting this very rural area being
fearful of the cost of an appeal is not
a reason to do the right thing which is
to reject this application as the desire
and alleged need for this Barn are
nothing to do with farming so I urge you
all to turn down this application once
and for all and to protect Elmore from
the ridiculous level of development M
and applications to build even more
unneeded and unsustainable building in
this most precious area of rural
Countryside in warshire asmore needs to
be protected not developed and that
protection lies with you and the adopted
local plan the purpose of planning is to
ensure that no harm is done harm will
continue to be done if this application
is granted today for yet another barn on
yet another supposed Farm all within
barely 600 yards of each other and the
agricultural consultant is paid for by
the applicants thank
you thank you very much councelor well
within your time uh members do we have
any questions for our W
member no nothing coming forward in
which case thank you very
much okay we now move on then to points
of clarification from our officers do we
have any points of
clarification C itward uh yes thank you
chair I wonder if I could just refer
back to one of the photographs the
officer showed uh which was facing
Westward from the propos side
please um there we go I think that's the
one I can see in the distance there
about I don't know 3 4 500 meters away I
think 500 meters looking at the the
sketched uh plan in the notes um is that
t Fields
itself that that building there yeah
that that's um that's on an adjacent
parcel and that was granted and that's
been also granted in agricultural
notification and that the adjacent
parcel is where on the site plan please
so let me just go
back so it effectively we are looking
across the site there so it would be
somewhere okay there and the ownership
of that adjacent pass is the same as the
ownership of the proposed site I um I
think it's a separate ownership separ
own I think it's separate ownership yeah
okay thank you thank you very much any
fur the points clarification Council
Keith
Lee thank you chair um yeah I'm I'm
interested in um exploring the size of
the site because um councilor wayy
hoggins described it as a patch of grass
and um Parish Council described it as
probably less than two acres yet I read
on page 10 that fox rural consider it to
be four acres can you can you clarify
that that for me and also whether or not
there are any restrictions on um
barns relating to the size of the field
or Farm is there anything that would
would guide us in respect to Barns put
up on very small plots of land because
the same could happen
again on the next parel of
land I mean in terms of the um of of the
need for the barn and the size of the
barn that that has been assessed by the
um agricultural consultant and they they
came back in their conclusion and
suggested that the size of the barn as
has been put forward is what is required
by this particular agricultural
holding so it's very much a sort of a
sight
specific assessment in this
case uh policy-wise as10 says that um uh
within the countryside it can be
acceptable to have a building or
structure related to agriculture where
it is required for such purposes our
consultation with Fox ra confirmed it's
required for the purposes of Agriculture
and that it's appropriate in scale to
the operations which the applicant says
they will be
undertaking thank you for
that councilor Perry next I
believe thank you chair can you just um
Can the officers advise the relevance
when the applicant's agent mentioned
that the applicant also owns the
adjacent
field my view is we can only look at
what's in front of
us in in the in the Square side of
things what I'm trying to get at is from
an agricultural bom perspective from a
planning point of view is it only
related to the
area can it only be used for the area
that is outlined in red or if it was
given planning permission could the
applicant use it to store vehicles for
neighboring other parts of land that it
may the applicant May
[Music]
own uh so this the assessment we've
undertaken and the assessment which Fox
raal our agricultural consultant would
have undertaken would have been a based
on information provided at the point of
the application which was this red line
boundary if the applicants have
subsequently acquired other land
associated with their agricultural
operation then that's not something
we've based our recommendation on and
doesn't isn't necessary for us to have
concluded that this is uh something we
want to recommend approval for we've
proposed in the um agenda a condition
which would restrict the purposes of the
building to agriculture it doesn't tie
it tightly to only agriculture that
occurs within the parcel of the land
shown in red on the screens now so if
they did acquire other land so long as
they would only using the barn for
agricultural purposes that would be
acceptable if it was in association with
that other
land thank you coun
Harvey um the fox rurals um
report if we were minded to
disregard that report on the basis of
other information that has been
presented to us um what sort of uh other
planning arguments would we need to uh
put into effect in order or to adopt in
order to come to that judgment on on a
planning
ground I think it would be it would be
up to members to to if if they had
reason to go against what what um the
conclusions were in the agricultural
consultant report it would be up to
members to put forward those those
reasons why why you didn't necessarily
agree with their
conclusion I take it that then what we
would be saying would be that
counselor's judgment on that particular
matter would be pitted against the
independent
agricultural Consultants point of view
and I presume we would simply say well
we we think different uh it's not big
enough to to Merit this
Bond I think members would have to have
some reasoned justification to um
disregard the expert advice which has
been sought from an independent
consultant I think there would have to
be strong evidence for that to appear as
though it was reasonable
Behavior
Council of
Fleming um it's been mentioned about
this uh adjacent acquisition of land is
it I know we're only judging what's
within the red lines but is this extra
land that they purchased is it adjacent
and adjoining the red line or don't you
know
that officers don't have any information
about that at the current time okay
thank
you C ke again thank thank you chairman
um could I ask I'm turning to page 12 it
says um the um it's just in respect of
uh the impact of landscape and the
character of the area the uh the report
states that the office has satisfied the
distinctive rural character of the site
and surrounding area be preserved um
what I'm interested to know is whether
or not there's a cumulative impact test
that could be applied to a series of
bars all within close proximity but all
meeting the requirements of a rural um
consultant view that such a barn was
required for um a 2 acre small holding
for example is there anything that would
allow us to consider the cumulative
impact a test of cumulative impact on
the landscape
character certainly I think members are
entitled to consider the impact of
proposed new buildings on the landscape
I
think the type of building that's being
proposed is not atypical for a rural
area it is a typical agricultural
building proposed on an
agricultural unit um I I I would
struggle to see how the cumulative
development of agricultural buildings on
agricultural properties is
unsympathetic to the character of the
landscape but members may take a a
different view if that's something they
wish to
do castle of Fleming
again just a quick one it was a question
that was asked earlier um we've we've
got three conflicting sizes of this land
is it a patch of grass is it two acres
or is it four that's that's my
answer
we understand it's four
acres Council pattingham um does the fox
report say that there'll be any
agricultural Contracting done by this
all this equipment um because there does
seem to be a lot of small agricultural
contractors that do work for the biggest
states that have similar patches of land
with with
barns
no I don't understand that to be the
basis they've reached their conclusions
I think it's really understood to be on
the basis of the operations that will
take place on this
land Council keithy again a follow up to
council Fleming's question page 10 core
strategy as 10 supports the building or
structure related to agricultural
forestry and it says the submitted
statement the justification statements
States the area is 1.2
hectares that's not 48 because is
it
um just looking at the rural planning
appraisal counselor which is which is
what was um undertaken so the background
and History Section says the applicants
own a 3 Acre block of land in which they
purchased in
2021 with which they have started a
mixed small holding which sheep poultry
and some horiculture a further one acre
of adjoining land is in the process of
being purchased added which I would
imagine is what was been referred to
earlier so the assessment has been
undertaken on the basis of four
acers any further points of
clarification councilor
Parry sorry to come back to the um
acreage again um but if the report is
referring to the adjacent piece of land
that has been
acquired that looks more than twice the
size of the red lined
area um I'm just a bit confused we're
getting
conflicting numbers and figures on the
size of the holding which um we've got
Fox's rural saying one thing we' got a
different figure that is I'm I'm
concerned that these figures contained
in the report may not could be being
taken out of context of what's actually
in front of us and they do not relate to
the redlined area and if they're talking
about the the whole of the adjacent
area that is certainly not it if if that
that square is meant to be one acre then
the red line area can't can't be more
than just over half an
acre
so I think as um coun keithly points out
the the red line area amounts to about
1.2 hectares which is
2.96
Acres um that is in page 10 of of your
agenda there is an additional acre being
picked up although we we haven't got
that as on a plan that's referred to in
the fox rural
appraisal so that would be one acre
unknown 2.9 Acres within the red line
boundary shown
here excuse me for coming back but we
are being asked to approve something
within the redlined area and now you're
saying that um fo rural have made their
appraisal on additional piece of land
that it's not marked by this red area
I'm I'm just trying to get my head
around that we have got to approve
what's in front of us which is the red
line area and therefore the fox rural
appraisal is ambiguous to what we have
in front of
us well as as Neil referred to before
the appraisal is based on the red line
in front of you but with the
understanding that additional land may
be added as part of the operation as it
as it goes along and that's the basis on
which Fox roll have made their
recommendation can I play that back to
you just so that I understand in
different ways so what you telling us is
that fox rural appraisal has been based
upon a patch of land which is of three
acres there is the prospect that a
further acre may be
bought but I'm implying from that that
even if this additional acre is not
bought Fox rural are still saying that
the 3 Acre plot merits this bar is that
correct I think that would be a
reasonable reading of the report
yes thank you very much any further
points of clarification I think fairly
exhaustive and rightfully
so okay we can then move on to the
debate who would like to
start anyone in particular I'll start
picking on
people councilor Fleming thank
you um if we look at purely the the red
line area 2.88 Acres as it's meant to be
or three acres rounded
up you could house 20 sheep on that so
that kind of makes it a small holding I
mean just after the war the the the
government created loads of uh small
Holdings that were about that sort of
size and and we're given agricultural
status and whatever else um so although
I hear all the arguments about
overdevelopment in the area I'm not
altogether sure that I've got enough uh
to go against the officer's
recommendation at this time so uh that
that's where I'm but I'm going to wait
and see wait and see what the rest have
to say thank thank you very much
councilor
Perry thank you um I can understand the
concern raised by the parish
council um but I'm not an agricultural
expert as already evidenced in some of
my
questioning um we
have an independent allbe it paid for by
the applicant of an from an agricultural
consultancy that they feel that the area
in the red line they're happy to support
this proposed
bar um it falls in line with
as10 from an agricultural
perspective it falls in line with
CS5 which is
landscaping and it also falls in line
with
cs9 design and distinctiveness
and whilst I don't particularly like
what's in front of me I think it's
helpful that the applicant is happy to
have a condition that the barn can only
be used for agricultural
purposes but I can see no material
planning reason to refuse it because we
have expert opinion socalled expert
opinion
um and therefore whilst I don't like
what's in front of me we also have the
no objection from warshire County
Council which was a a major concern that
we had and I'm happy with the conditions
that they have put forward um so I have
I can't see a reason to refuse this but
to go along with the officer's
recommendation and therefore happy to
propose not so much happy to propose but
I will propose because I can't see any
material planning reasons against it um
because I'm not an expert in agriculture
thank you councilor Perry um I I do um
largely agree with you on all those
points I believe Council Keith you name
thanks chairman
um I think uh you know the discussion
we've had hinges a lot of the concerns
hinge on the justification for bar on
what appears to be very small plot of
land so I also acknowledge the concerns
of the parish council because I could
see maybe going forwards half a dozen
barns on half a dozen small
plots like councelor Parry though I'm
not an agricultural expert I I do
question whether or not you could get an
agricultural holding certificate on
something so small I thought that the
scale was larger but they might not need
that they might not be applying for
various grants and subsidies and such
like um I think the evidence in front of
us um from what we've heard Fox rural
are happy that this passes the test and
the size of the barn is appropriate to
the land shown in red um and I like
councelor Perry can see no material
reasons for deviating from the
recommendations of the officer so on
that basis I'm happy to Second councelor
Paris prop proposal to go with a
recommendation from
officers thank you very much Kath
littlewood thank you chair
um whereas the it seems the evidence
suggested and put before us is is is
positive in support I have I have some
problems because during the
presentations we've been talking about
2.9 Acres we be talking about four acres
we can only look at the amount of land
that this application appear applies to
and that is the smaller parcel and what
this plan this application doesn't show
as far as I've seen anyway is the amount
of that total acreage that's been taken
off for hardstanding already it's been
in the area to have the construction
placed upon so I think there's some
difficulties there however having said
that if we are talking about uh what to
2 and a half acres of production area uh
then that would support sheet and um and
again I Echo what's previously being
said uh by other counselors that um
whereas I'm not totally comfortable with
it I can't see any planning reasons not
to support thank you very much um yes
and I I I understand the those
reservations one of the reasons I was
quite happy to be exhaustive on our
points of clarification was because I
did want exactly all these uh
technicalities to be voiced and I feel
that that was very useful U to informing
our debate when anyone else like to
speak no uh in which case we have a
proposal um to Grant in L along with the
in line with the officer's
recommendations um and the updates on
the update sheet which has been
seconded um there have been no other
proposals in which case we can go to the
vote can I see all those in favor please
that's you anous chair thank you very
much in which case uh committee resolves
to Grant application
627f
L Right Moving on then um our next item
item number five is application 23 sl01
027 ful land triangular plot to the
north of Windmill Lane ladbrook our
presenting officer is again Neil uh when
you're ready take it
away thank you chairman um the
application site is shown on the screen
with the uh with the with the black dot
and the application is for a change of
use from agricultural to equestrian
that's private equestrian use
and the erection of a stable building
comprising of two stables and a feed
tack
[Music]
room so just showing the application
site in more
detail points to point out from here are
the um public foot paath which runs
through the corner of the site and some
TPO trees to the
South so just looking at the existing
and proposed site plan again you can see
reference to the TPO trees there so the
application is for the
um the building there the stable
building and then there's a bark pathway
leading to it there is a existing stable
building on the adjoining site which it
would be located adjacent
to so just looking at the um the
elevation so a relatively simple stable
Block in um in
appearance which would have um shiplap
Timber cladding and a dark gray bimman
base corrugated
roofing and so just looking at the floor
plans we'd have two Stables the tack
room with um a WC as
well so to give members an understanding
of the site of I've got some some
photographs um now what I should point
out at this point is a number of the
photographs are showing the existing
boundary fence in
situ um in this Photograph and other
ones now this is not part of the current
planning
application um together with the removal
of any grass Turf um and this is
currently being looked at by the
planning enforcement team
as has been detailed in the committee
report so this is a um photograph from
outside the site just on the um on the
southern boundary so you can see one of
the TPO trees along
there and this is a wider view looking
to it's taken from outside but looking
into the
site and so this is looking more into
the site um
there is a currently a caravan on site
or there was when these photographs were
taken at the beginning of
September um members would have noticed
in the update sheet that there is
reference to an updated condition
regarding the removal of
that um there's also a gap in the the
fence there which is um to allow um
users of the foot paath to go through
the
site so that's looking from the south
again to into to the
site and again looking you can see the
existing adjoining stable building which
I referred to
earlier and again where the TPO trees
are and the existing stable building
next
door and that is looking from the other
end of the site looking back to where we
were just taking the photograph so you
can see the um existing Caravan there as
a as a reference
point chairman there are updates as
detailed in the update sheet including
an updated condition in respect of the
removal of the existing Caravan which I
referred to earlier and chairman the
application is recommended for Grant
thank
you thanks very much Neil uh we can now
move on then to our first Speaker who is
councelor
Groves of lab Brook par
Council good evening
counselor uh so you've got three minutes
uh it's the button on the right hand
side um and the red light should come on
when the microphone is on I'm happy to
give you a 30 second warning if you're
okay with
that of course that's right
yes okay and when you're ready take it
away thank you tonight is about making
sure development doesn't happen
unchecked under the GU of a question my
job is to highlight the St contrast
between what's really going on and the
application we have no issue with the
request to change agricultural land to
equestrian but that's not what's
happened the applicant has undertaken
unapproved development work outside of
this application and out of keeping with
the spirits and objectives of your local
plan first the legislation section 55 of
the Town and Country planning Act of
1990 defines development as carrying out
building engineering mining or other
operations in in on over or under land
the applicant has conducted significant
and intensive Earthworks stripping the
land of All Glass grass removing all
hedge RS in nesting season erecting six-
foot fencing enclosing the entire site
carried out numerous large excavations
and deployed hundreds of tons of gravel
and hardcore using two large excavators
on site for months working around the
clock all this equates to an engineering
operation or development as prev
previously defined and no permitted
development rights under schedule two of
the Town and Country planning order 20
uh 2015 allow equestrian activity the
applicant has therefore no permission to
develop and has undertaken a legal
operation turning now to the planning
application the first strategic
objective of your local plan States
clearly that the rural character of the
district will be maintained and enhanced
policy as10 supports sequestering
activities providing they minimize
impact on the character of the local
landscape and paragraph 84 C of the
national planning policy framework also
states that rural developments must
respect the character of the countryside
so the illegal development work that's
been undertaken here so far laughs in
the face of these key policies and we
can all see where this is going without
rejecting this application outright or
at the very least putting rigorous
consent uh for the consent to be
accompanied by rigorous conditions
namely one basic The Paddock must be
restored currently seriously it's a
building Society without a blade of
grass so I'm wondering what I'm looking
out there two the boundary treatment
must respect the character and impact on
the landscape horses are kept in post
and rail not box 6ot fences the size of
the stable building is not larger than
necessary this is a 1.48 site that
barely barely supports with grass two
horses and we've got a l and two h
stables in summary ladbrook Parish
Council supports the principle of a
padic and stable but given the
devastation that has taken place so far
unhindered we do not trust the applicant
who uphold this without being compelled
to do so by means of stringent
conditions in the light of the district
council not agreeing to any conditions
of this nature we very very firmly
maintain our objection thank
you bang on three minutes thank you very
much members do we have any questions
for our Parish
counselor nothing forthcoming no in
which case thank you very much for your
contribution this evening thank you
thank you very
much okay we now move on then to our
final speaker who is the uh Ward member
councelor AR
strander good evening counselor good
evening uh so you've got five minutes
I'm happy to give you a 30 second
warning um otherwise when you're ready
take it away I do have some photographs
okay great thank
you hello committee and thank you for
your time and consideration of this
planning issue there is a saying I'm
sure many of you are familiar with if it
looks like a duck swims like a duck and
quacks like a duck then it probably is a
duck this concept is used to test the
reasoning in an argument implying that a
person can identify something by looking
at its
characteristics in our current context
for a change of use from agricultural to
equestrian one would look at this site
and you would have to agree that it
doesn't look sound or feel like an
equestrian
setup this Common Sense approach whilst
perhaps not a planning point in and of
itself still seems relevant to good
decision
making the following photos exemp
exemplify this point firstly the site
has been with heavy machinery photo one
and entirely covered in hardcore and
gravel photo
2 this is not typical of an equestrian
site secondly the whole site has been
surrounded by a six foot high Clos
boarded fence also shown in
photo2 this two is not standard for
padding horses where post and rail is
much more typical as shown in photo
3 these are material planning
considerations pertaining to design and
appearance specifically policy CS5 of
the core strategy aims to maintain the
landscape character and quality by
ensuring that development takes place in
a manner that minimizes its impact and
where possible incorporates measures to
enhance the
landscape this Associated Landscaping
was removed from the application because
the agent said it was permitted
development this point now appears to be
in dispute and a matter for enforcement
but the committee May nonetheless like
to have it in mind when understanding
the context and concern of ladbrook
residents regarding the site and its
future
use these photos also highlight the
point made by Miss Groves a moment ago
that the works undertaken here
constitute an engineering operation if
we could have photo one again please and
hence can be considered development
without permission according to section
55 of the Town and Country planning act
1990 it is thus an illegal operation
requiring
enforcement this site has been the
predominant issue affecting ladbrook
from for many months which is
unsurprising given the provoc
provocations of the owner a large area
adjacent to the ladbrook bypass not even
part of the site was flailed during the
nesting season for no apparent reason
that's shown in photo four please in
addition Hedges all around the site have
been removed and trees cut back policy
cs9 of the core strategy States the
development should contribute positively
to the character and identity of an area
respecting local topography and
Landscape
features the ladbrook parish plan in
section 16 emphasizes the importance of
the rural environment and the
overwhelming support for protecting it
the destruction of habitat in the form
of flailed verges and illegal removal of
hedro during the nesting season is
entirely contrary to the core strategy
and the parish plan furthermore the
parish plan also emphasizes the
significance of the local rights of way
which are regularly used by residents
public footpath sm90 passes across the
southeast corner of the site yet has not
been included in their site plan also to
note it has already been necessary to
Ser to serve two stop notices on this
site when this application first arose I
consulted with the council's deputy
leader someone with a much more
experience than I have on planning
issues our combined judgment resulted in
suggesting several enforceable
conditions to reassure understandably
nervous residents some of these have
been included in the officer's report
which we are grateful for however the
more substantive ones for example
relating to the types of vehicles that
could enter the site no Caravans and
prohibiting overnight stays failed the
reasonableness test and so have not been
included leaving the residents of
ladbrook with a situation that appears
unenforcable and vulnerable to further
provocation by the
landowner in close I hope you will
consider the points I have raised raed
relating to the expressed desire of the
ladbrook parish to maintain the
character of the rural environment as
espoused in the ladbrook parish plan I
would therefore urge the committee to
firstly acknowledge the point the point
raised that thus far sorry that the work
thus far carried out constitutes
development and is thus illegal
requiring immediate enforcement action
and secondly that if despite all the
evidence presented here you are still
minding to Grant this
application the committee consider the
conditions suggested by Miss Groves
namely that the paddock be restored to
grass that there be control of the
boundary treatment and to impose limits
on the size of the stable building I
thank you all again for your time and
careful consideration of this complex
issue thank you very much counselor just
on time um members do we have any
questions for our war member Council of
passingham first
do you know whether the Hedge was
grubbed up or disc
Copic I believe they were removed sorry
I believe they were actually removed
removed so grubbed up yes right
thanks just for a point of clarification
from me that we do have to speak about
exactly what's in front of us as the
application tonight and appreciating
some of the the me war members speech
related to um enforcement action we do
have to be very concise on what is
discussed just want that to be
absolutely clear Council Fleming
next I'm not an expert on Ducks but I'm
almost an expert on horses I've owned
them for 50 years we've never owned a
horse in 50 years that could graze on
that
land and uh so from that perspective
there are certain words that I can't use
in what I want to say um but this really
does not look like an equestrian
development in any shape or coun of
Fleming could you come around to a a
question for our war M please okay sorry
question is have you ever seen any
horses on
site um I have not
no councilor
Keithley thanks chair um councilor
Ostrander you showed a photograph of um
building works and piles of of Hardcore
suggesting that the site had been
covered in that uh is that actually the
case because some of the photographs
we've seen show grass having been
removed and weeds growing but you
suggested that the hardcore have been
spread across the application site
literally hundreds of tons of Hardcore
and gravel have been spread across the
site we are all three of us rather
surprised by those photographs that were
shown earlier um presumably there are
weeds growing through that hardcore and
gravel but that is what is underneath
those okay thank you councelor Harvey
yep counselor um I think the second
photograph you showed was of post rail
um just I wasn't quite switched on when
when you refer to that uh did that post
and rail photograph was that of the site
or was it an illustration of elsewhere
that's to illustrate what a more typical
Paddock would look like so what we're
talking about is it was originally
bounded by Hedges and it's now got
offense yes fine thank
you any further questions from our W
member
no in which case thank you very much for
your
contribution okay um we have no more
speakers in which case we move to points
of clarification to our officers any
points of
clarification C Keithley thank you chair
uh yeah one question the close board
fence that we've seen with the concrete
posts am I right in understanding that
that is outside the application
boundary that is not part of the current
planning application and is subject to
enforcement but is it outside the
application boundary it's not part of
the planning application right okay
thank
you councelor Harvey next I'll preface
this by saying I have experienced in my
ward of uh a request for um a
development for uh equestrian facility
for private purposes in darling Scott I
can I can think of an example so in some
circumstances this is perfectly
reasonable um my question is based upon
the information that we've been
presented with this evening um is is
this an application for land to go from
agricultural use to equestrian use my
question really is is this still
agricultural
land I think the lawful use of the land
at the current time is
agricultural councilor letterwood thank
you chair uh question to the officer you
went on site to take photographs and I
just want clarification did you notice
what the state of the ground was when
you took those photographs did you feel
it was grass that had been sewn after
being tilled or did that look like it
was Hardcore underneath because I want a
clarification of what their Ward members
mention earlier in her
talk um unfortunately I cannot answer
that question I I didn't take those
photographs that the case officer took
those photographs and they were taken on
the 1st of
September I'm led to
believe
yeah Council
Perry thank you chair um I would like
the officers to give me some indic um
with regard to the building
which has been identified as for two
Stables
um it seems quite a
large the Staples seem
extremely large to house holes are there
any sort of
guidelines when for for stabling
purposes at all um because obviously
it's it it it does look quite a large
building and then we have a large tack
room and then we have you know a kitchen
area or
WC um adjacent or we certainly have
drainage coming into the to the building
um I'm not an exp
expert but I would just like some
guidance um because it's meant it's
described as two Stables I I'm afraid my
eyesight's not very good could could you
just give me some clarification on the
size of the individual Stables please
and the
overall Dimension I it's probably in the
report but I'm just struggling with my
eyes at the
moment
sorry sorry um approximately 3 and a
half meters in height um and in terms of
some of the
measurements um so it's
approximately 13 m in
width um and in depth it's with the
apron at the front it's um about 5.8
m
just carrying on for that is there a a
standard or reasonable comparison
to um other Stables as as to whether
this constitutes a reasonable size for
two
horses I think it's fair to say we don't
have that information available to us at
the current time it looks to be from the
measurements at least
4.2 met wide for each
stable
um those counselors with experience
might be able to speak to this better
than ourselves I know the British horse
Society does offer guidance but again I
don't have that information with me
today
unfortunately okay thank you um further
points of
clarification councelor Keith yes thanks
chair um counselor
Ostrander mentioned the possibility of
conditions relating to overnight
stays and um the keeping of Caravans on
site did I hear correctly that that that
that the response to that request had
been that those might be unreasonable
conditions I I can't remember what
exactly was said about
it yeah I think in in terms of the um of
of the conditions with with with the um
with the removal of the Caravan that
that's in the update sheets where um we
would look to to set a time scale for
for the removal of that from the site
which is a slight adaptation to what's
in the um in the committee report in
terms of conditions generally there are
there are effectively six tests that you
apply to
conditions which are set out in the mppf
in the in the planning practice guidance
so that is are they necessary
enforcable precise relevant to planning
relevant to the development permitted
and reasonable in all other
respects so that that's the Judgment
that officers have to apply in applying
conditions to um planning
permission so officers have carefully
considered in the consultation responses
the conditions which have been put
forward um and have reached the
conclusion that the conditions which are
detailed in the um in the committee
report are the ones which meet those
conditions tests and as such can be
applied I think it's fair to say that
the description of development and the
purpose for which it you know the plans
we have don't allow for things like
residential accommodation on the site
there's no permission um sought or
inferred to be granted by the grant of a
a stable for example for the citing of
Caravans on the site which would need
its separate consent if that were to
occur on the site it would again be
another matter for
enforcement could I follow it is a very
quick followup it's one thing to say I
think that the Caravan that's already on
site should be
removed but then another Caravan could
come a different color presumably and
and also another Caravan could come
along and I think that um there are
rights permitted rights are they not to
to site mobile temporary accommodation
on land
for certain periods would I be right in
saying that that there are I mean the
condition that you're applying doesn't
say there should be no Caravans on site
what it says is the Caravan that's on
site should be taken away that's subtly
different yes you're correct it's it's
not necessary for our planning consent
to close off every possible alternative
use that could occur on the site any
permission that might arise out of this
planning application wouldn't Grant
consent for other Caravans on the site
or the storage of vehicles for example
the other kind of activities which could
be considered development and would need
their own planning permission in their
own right this test is the test of
relevancy in essence you know we're
handling today an application for
equestrian use of the land and for the
Stables you know we don't need to close
off future applications or consider what
other applications might come down the
line we should you know play the
application that's in front of us and
none other C
Harvey I'm going to answer my own
question and then see see if you think
I've got the answer right I'm going to
make the assumption that whether a
planning consent if granted is
implementable in practice whether that
is a material consideration when
considering whether to Grant or not it
is not that's my first question my
second question is there are
circumstances and we've had one tonight
where um there was an issue which
required or would benefit from an
independent report from an expert um
it would it not be reasonable in this
particular instance to ask for a report
from somewhere like the British horse
Society about the suitability of this
triangular piece of land uh as an
equestrian
location the answer to your first
question is yes you're correct the
Implement implementability if you like
of a planning application is not really
relevant to whether or not we determine
it favorably we determine in accordance
with the development plan andless
material considerations indicate we
should do otherwise
um should we seek advice from an
independent expert in respect of um uh
equine activities on this site officers
haven't considered that to be necessary
to make our recommendation members may
take a different
view any further points of
clarification no in which case we can
move to the debate who'd like to start C
little thank you chair I I have to say
I'm deeply uncomfortable with this um I
know we can't consider the uh the
treatment of the boundary but anybody
knows anything about horses would never
ever in their right mind put in um the
type of fencing that's been placed in
this the second point is the condition
of the land if as we heard hardcore has
been placed down across the whole of it
it cannot be grazed that makes me think
therefore there are other reasons for
doing this and I think that is deceitful
potentially and without further
clarification of all these issues which
I believe are
material and uh there it's reasonable
for us to ask for further clarification
information and we should push this back
at this time with a refusal um pending
further information and
reapplication and I make that a proposal
please thank you very much Council lwood
we'll come back to you uh for some more
detail in the councel Harvey next can I
speak before that has been
seconded um because um I share the Deep
S I can feel I can feel the the unease
within the chamber on this particular
application and I do understand the
difficulties the officers have of um not
necessarily always being able to define
a duck as a duck so to speak
um if if we are minded if we were to be
minded to refuse we'd have to have a
good reason to do that in the face of a
recommendation based upon an analysis of
the planning requirements um I would
like to propose that this item is
deferred pending the receipt of a report
from a suitably
qualified um independent body or
individual
more than happy to leave that to the
officers to decide uh to be so that we
have advice we can rely upon upon the
suitability of this land uh to be used
for equestrian
purposes I don't think we are in a POS
well no I personally don't think I'm in
a position to come to a view on this
particular matter unless I am absolutely
certain that if granted this would be
suitable land for equestrian use I'm not
in that position I would like to be in
that
position thank you uh councelor Perry
next thank you chair um councelor Harvey
is stol in my thunder because I was
going to go down the same route and
actually for the reasons of of CS5
landscape which I feel the character of
the landscape does not
reflect um I'm not an expert on ecoin
but my concerns are that the landscape
has been altered from
agricultural um setting and therefore it
is out of character for an ecoin
facility at this in in terms of what we
have been shown in front of us and
therefore I think that in itself is is
good reason for deferral in order to get
some expert opinion for for it
um it has all the Hallmarks of a trojan
horse thank thank you councelor Perry um
go back to councelor
littlewood thank you again I'm happy to
um withdraw my proposal in the light of
uh councelor Harvey's proposal and I'll
be happy to Second it but wait other
debate lovely thank you very much for
that councilor Fleming
next in its current state uh This Land
is totally unsustainable for keeping
ponies or horses on so on the basis that
I mean I would go for Outlet refusal
however I'm quite happy to go along with
the the current proposal because I think
anybody with any kind of equin knowledge
at all and I do think I have got it
after 50 years of keeping the things um
it's totally unsustainable there isn't
an animal on this earth that could graze
or or live on that land so from that
perspective if we can get somebody in
there who really does have the the
figures to back it up um I'd like to go
to to Second what the others are saying
okay thank you very much um yes I mean I
for my part I think I I share the
reservations I think we we do have to
look at what we have in front of us so I
can't in good faith look at a refusal at
this point but I think more information
is required to be able to make an
assessment for its use as equestrian
land um I'm just going to have a very
quick conversation with our officers
make sure that they've got enough uh
for for that sort basis of of that
decision at the moment and then we can
look to move
on jly good okay um so we've got a
proposal to defer by CLE Harvey and was
it councilor Perry who seconded yeah and
shortly thereafter councelor itward uh
counc did you want to add anything else
uh yes I i' I'd like to to make sure
that when we do have the external report
the independent report that we insist on
that report having had a site visit to
inspect the ground condition I think
that perfectly reasonable um councilor
par um in addition to as part of this I
also would would like reference to the
size of the
stabling um typical stabling
per four-legged animal pleas as well
yeah that that all seems agreeable as
well um I don't think anyone else wants
to contribute so the proposal is to
defer the application pending
uh expert advice uh on the use of the
land for equestrian purposes can I see
all those in favor please that's
unanimous chair unanimous in which case
um application
23127 fu is
deferred okay uh I'm going to take a TW
minute minute Comfort break so we can um
have a temporary recess and then we'll
um move on to the next application thank
you
okay thank you for bearing with us we
now move on to item six which is
application
23520 ful red horse Veil limited
Windmill Farm banry Road oxil our
presenting officer is Paul Thompson uh
when you're ready take it away thank you
chair good evening one and all
um attentive uh attendees to committee
will might recognize this one we granted
permission for it just over three years
ago uh in 2020 you'll recall what
happened next uh that rather intruded
upon the applicants plans for uh
continuing the development and so we
we've got a resubmission now nothing
material has changed in terms of policy
or the uh it or the proposal itself uh
it's a straight resubmission just to
resurrect the permission so we are on
bamb road uh a little way out of
oxhill uh this is the application site
public right of way leads from the front
of the site um passes through to the
north that's the green dashed
line relevant part of the site is
towards the South near the uh Junction
with the public Highway um you'll note
that there's a building there currently
that's the dashed outline and it's going
to be replaced with uh a building of
about the same footprint but on a
slightly more regular
layout uh this is what it will look
like oh sorry that's what it does look
like currently um this is what it will
look like um a little neater and that's
what it currently looks like in
person uh my recommendation
unsurprisingly chair is to Grant
permission uh as we did
previously thank you very much Paul uh
so we only have one speaker who is the
agent for the applicant Natasha blackm
silver welcome
again thank you for bearing with us in
the in the in between uh you've got
three minutes um I have to give you 30
second warning otherwise take it away
thank you good evening I here to speak
on behalf of the applicant in support of
this application for replacement storage
building at windmore Farm Ox Hill this
application is a resubmission of a
scheme originally approved in 2020 which
lapsed earlier this year there have been
no material changes to planning policy
the application site and context since
the original scream was approved and
there have been no changes to the
proposed building red horse veils
limited is a thriving rural business
specializing in the sale and
distribution of Fuels Building and farm
supplies it's been located at Wind Farm
since 1977 and is a large local employer
that is looking to improve its
facilities the current storage building
to be replaced is outdated and of a poor
ad hoc construction additionally it is
not tool enough to allow the necessary
storage racking and Machinery to move
items in and out this application seeks
to regularize the ad hoc arrangement of
this building and more efficiently
manage the existing business operations
on the site through a purpose-built
storage building the proposed building
will provide sufficient height for the
racking Machinery to easily enter and
erress the store and it will be metal
clad to match the existing buildings on
site with roller shutter doors these
materials were previously approved under
thee under the 2020
application we are in a relatively
unique position in that the case officer
is recommending the application for
approval the ward member and Parish
Council are also supporting the scheme
and there have been no objections from
consules the application is being heard
at committee tonight solely because the
applicant is the brother-in-law of
councelor Wally hoggins in summary the
scheme is policy compliant and supports
the continued operation of an
established rural business there have
been no changes to the proposed building
since the original scheme was approved
in
2020 the officer has suggested several
conditions be attached to the decision
notice which we will happily accept we
hope that this is a straightforward
decision to approve the scheme in line
with the officer's recommendation and
trust that members will agree I'm happy
to answer any questions you may have
thank
you thank you very much well within time
members do we have any questions
councelor Keith Lee yes thank you very
much chair
um the question really relates to um
sort of sustainable construction and a
low carbon future and I know the
business well because I use it I'm a
customer um and uh I'd be interested to
know if there are any proposals I don't
see them to to have um solar panels or
something similar because the business
does distribute fossil fuels so I
wondered whether know you could comment
on
that uh there are currently no solar
panels attached to the building that is
proposed I don't know whether a
condition to that effect could be added
I don't think the applicants would be
against it but this was a
straightforward resubmission of the 2021
that was approved and we've made no
changes yeah I understand that thank you
we got any further points sorry
questions for applicant no in which case
thank you very
much right we do now move on to points
of clarification do we have any points
clarification from for
officers counc passingham point of
information what what's what's the
relevance of the applicant being a
brother-in-law of a
counselor we're required to bring to
committee any such
application because they might have an
under the delegation scheme that's it's
it's just a the council is not on this
committee but it still happens any M
sorry is any member of the council
regardless of whether they're on the
committee or
not okay councelor Keithley yes just in
respect to the question the applicants
agent um what what do the officers feel
about the uh whether it's appropriate or
not to consider a condition in relation
to um solar panels on this
building a laudable aim counselor but I
think it would fail the test of
reasonableness simply because we didn't
do it last time and the policy context
hasn't changed including the Declaration
of climate emergency so I think we would
struggle to justify
that any further points of clarification
in which case we can move to the debate
councelor Harvey raring to um can I
propose Grant and call for a second it
please councilor
Perry please to Second this um
application for Grant TR good um any
further contributions to the debate
councelor Keithley thank you yeah I'm
happy to go along with that I'm just a
bit disappointed that we the applicant
hasn't been a little bit more Forward
Thinking in respect of um climate
emergency and uh proposed actions to at
least be seen to be doing something
towards
it uh Julie noted thank you uh for your
comments there any further Council of
Fleming yeah the only thing I would say
is as as it's a storage building I don't
know what uh what they would be able to
do with the electric that they harvest
off off uh solar panels on that
particular application so you know for
that perspective that doesn't sway me
one way or the other okay no worries um
I have nothing further to add um in
which case we have a proposal and
seconded to Grant in line with the
officer's recommendation can I see all
those in favor please that's unanimous
chair excellent in which case committee
resolves to Grant application 23/
ful okay we can now move on to our final
application of this evening which is TPO
0044 uh STC 723 ragley estate Arrow
oler our presenting officer is Sarah
flirty once you're uh situated and ready
uh feel free to take it
away
sharing what's going
on
sorry about that thank you chairman this
item relates to True preservation order
TPO 004 04 which relates to two lime
trees the application site is located to
the southeast of the a422 in Arrow and
the trees are denoted by the black
circles on this plan let's go to the
next slide as a bit clearer there we go
they're denoted by the red circles and
the green dots in the center of the plan
so the site is in the west M green Bo
Arden special landscape area and is
within Arrow Conservation Area there are
number of listed buildings nearby T1 is
the northernmost tree seen here if you
can see my cursor and T2 is located to
the South you'll also see the green dash
line that denotes a public right of way
and another one over
here so here we have some images of the
trees in question uh this is T1 this
phot is taken in August 2023 and this
photo is taken facing the Southwest with
the tree in question indicated by the
arrow another picture of the tree here
we facing the
north it's another image of the tree
taken from within the estate facing
Northwest the public right way just runs
to the right of the image this is T2
which is at the junction of the
a422 image taken facing north another
photo of T2 all these photos are in
August 2023 as you'll
see and here we have some images of the
trees in Winter these were taken in
December
2022 at the time that the original TPO
provisional TPO was served
chairman members have three options as
to how to determine the order as set out
on page 46 of the agenda for the reasons
set out in the committee report it's
officer's recommendation to confirm the
order as made uh there is an update in
the update sheet relating to the parish
council's comments on the provision
order thank
you thank you very much um members we
have no um speakers for this item in
which case we move to points of
clarification um any members like to
raise anything councilor Keithley thanks
chair when I read the papers
I I became aware that there might be a
difference in technical opinion between
the agents aboriculture
aboriculture
and our own aboriculture
alist um the question is how how does
that arise when one would have thought
not being an expert but one would have
thought that there had been a standard
methodology ology for assessing the
condition of a
tree thanks for the question yeah
there's um there's a bit in the report
about this written by the tree officer
um I believe that her assessment was
that the their commission tree offic
comments related to the trees as a whole
rather than specifically focusing on
individual trees um I don't know if
richer would like to add anything more
to that um well they they used a method
that was for um risk assessment but it's
a bit heavy-handed in uh respect to Tree
Management Tree Management can done be
be done by many ways it doesn't require
the falling of trees that are perfectly
healthy and could live for another 150
years it's the lack of appropriate
management and falling them isn't
appropriate management what you could do
is you could Crown Lift Crown reduce you
could Deadwood you could actually Copus
you could actually poad a lime for ever
in a day so the trees have another 150
years of good healthy life they're a
cultural asset and they're a landscape
asset and for that purpose they reach
the criteria for TPO scoring 15 points
on Tempo which is an evaluation
evaluation method for imunity Value the
method they've used is a risk assessment
method so they're diametrically
opposed the bit I was referring to was
at the bottom of page 43 the last
paragraph um says um it would the agent
tree risk survey gave General overview
comments and recommendations of the
entire group which was five trees that
were subject to the tree notification
220 3468 tree um they were in different
states of Health the five trees hope
that anwers the
question thank you it it does um it does
help I also noted that there was a
question about whose responsibility it
might be if subsequently one of the
trees or a branch fell down and the
reason I asked the question in the first
place a friend of mine drove into a tree
that had fallen on on of the road and it
rode his car off he
successfully uh pursued a claim through
the land owners that had the
tree if You' like to elaborate the um
onus remains with the owner of the tree
um not the district council it's the
owner of the tree's
responsibility thanks that's what I
thank you Council Harvey um can I take
the the opportunity to make a fool of
myself um there are a series of trees
planted in
1910 and a good number of them have
gone uh these are two
exceptions um
[Music]
and the trees exhibit normal sort of um
behavior for trees of that type they're
very resilient to development um and
very adaptable trees uh the other trees
may have been fouled prematurely in my
view um so the lime trees can actually
go rotten at the but base but they have
a cambium circle round which is actually
structurally sound and they can go on
for a long long time like that um then
the trees can be managed so that you can
reduce the the crown um to take some of
the loading off that and you can remove
Deadwood they can be pollarded and
ultimately they can be cassed so
ultimately the trees have got another
150 years of valuable life left in them
but we would also encourage replacement
of trees when they're fouled uh I note
in the comments by Ruth um that some
replacement trees have been planted and
that's ongoing but the management is a
bit
heavy-handed any comment to that is
QED thank you very much any further
points of
clarification which case we can move to
the debate would anyone like to start
counc
Fleming this is this is a joining Ward
to me I've been driving past these trees
since
1967 um first on the school bus and then
obviously the thing the the reason some
of those trees haven't survived next to
that tree is ragley sawmill used to be
at the end of the drive and that's one
of the reasons a lot of the trees didn't
survive um so from my
perspective I I would suggest that we
keep the tree the the tree preservation
order um because ragy estate are very
very proficient at how to keep these
trees and keep them in good Nick um so
from that perspective uh you know I'd be
thinking that we ought to propose that
we retain the tree preservation
order thank you very much that's
proposal um just for clarification uh
point I which would be confirm the order
as
made is that right your proposal is uh
to to confirm the order as made yes okay
thank you councelor Harvey
seconded thank you very much councelor
passingham yeah I I fully support that
they look fantastic trees to me uh
and I don't see why if there are
branches hanging off uh like they claim
they could be um removed by by tree
surgeons and mature trees like that are
fantas ftic for biodiversity any
replacement trees would take a 100 years
to become so good in terms of supporting
Wildlife so it's very important to
preserve trees like that so fully
support it thank you very much um any
further contribution to debate in which
case we have a proposal uh which has
been seconded to confirm the order as
made can I see all of those in favor
please that's unanimous jff unanimous in
which case uh committee
resolves to confirm the tree order as
made for application TPO
z44 uh can let move on to our final item
eight urgent
business no bu no urgent business in
which case the meeting is
closed